the ramsay show you can be intentional
about your character
you can have money and a career you are
the hero
in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life
and your money i'm christy wright ramsey
personality
and i'm joined today by my fellow ramsay
personality anthony o'neill
anthony i'm excited about this christy
you in the big chair today
hey we've gotten to host a lot together
lately and i'm excited about this all
right man i'm excited too chrissy this
is gonna be fun
so here's the thing when you and i get
together we get feisty and get fired up
and we are answering
your calls today america so give us a
call triple eight eight two five
five two two five if you have a question
about money if you have a question about
business y'all know i love helping you
start a side business grow your small
business
lead a team or if you have a question
just about life
maybe it's a difficult situation you're
not sure which
choice to make anthony and i love to
coach you
help you think it through and make the
best decision for you while we're at it
anthony tell them where they can follow
you
on instagram and twitter hey man well
you know you can follow me uh on
instagram at
o'neil uh i'm not really on twitter that
much oh it's instagram that's your
favorite
same twitter's for the old people i
learned so much every time i get to host
with you this is really education for me
uh i also love instagram at christy b
wright you can send us some questions
there maybe we'll have time to throw
some of those in there today
we're gonna be with you all day
answering your questions about
money business and life that's triple
eight eight two five
five two two five anthony before we go
to the phones and we've got a few
callers already lined up here but i
wanted to take a second to just
recap for people maybe some people that
are listening today that are new
maybe some people that might have
forgotten recap for people a little bit
about what we do as ramsay personalities
everyone knows dave ramsey the man they
know ramsay's solutions they know the
dave ramsey show
and now we're ramsey show and we are
really being able to help people
in more ways than just money and so i'd
love to to kick it off and you tell us a
little bit about
kind of how you came here to ramsey
solutions and who you love to help and
how you love to help them and then i'll
do the same
man you know my message uh christy is uh
within my brand
um here at ramsey solutions i'm really
focusing on having a real
relevant and relatable conversation
around your life
around building true wealth by
eliminating debt and really start
preparing for
building wealth and leaving a legacy and
then also healthy relationships
you know because when it comes to money
one of the main reasons why
i racked up all the debt that i did and
became homeless christy
was because of the relationships that i
had i was trying to impress her
i was trying to impress them and i was
racking up all this debt trying to hang
with
billy and jane trying to impress the
joneses
but billy and jane and the jones is when
i racked up all this debt
no one really came to help me you know
no one came and offered me a place to
uh to lay my head no one offered me a
place to eat when i was homeless
no one even offered me a place to take a
shower and so for me within my brand
here
i'm really having that real relevant and
relatable conversation to help people
make better decisions
when it comes to just their life yeah
and building healthy relationships
and let's build true wealth i think a
lot of people get confused here that we
just want you to get out of debt
and live like you're getting out of debt
for the rest of your life now we want
you to get out of debt so you can enjoy
your life
yeah and go after your dreams and your
goals and if that's a
dream car a dream house freedom joy
peace you name it
i want to help that happen specifically
that younger age though
you know that younger 18 to about 34 35
years old
um and just really have a heart for that
generation you have a great line that i
i quote you all the time the caliber of
your future
is determined by the choices you make
today and yes and you're talking about
money but you're talking about more than
just money
that's really everything absolutely and
you're having this conversation on your
new podcast the table so tell people
where they can connect with that
oh man i'm loving christy right now we
need to have her host uh more often
james uh
can we make that happen this is good for
people to know what we're up to besides
being in this studio we love helping
people through the ramsay show but also
you're helping people in other ways than
that i sure am christian
i love you um you know you can go to
anthonynow.com and you go to the show
page and you see that we have a youtube
show that's doing very well over there
about 200 plus
thousand young people follow me on
youtube and we just launched my podcast
last month
and it's doing very well as well as as
well there so
uh come on over there specifically to
that younger age i mean it's hard it's
for everyone i don't know what's in here
and say if you're older than 34 or 35
don't rock with you boy
but what i'm saying other than that
don't worry hey yeah but what i am
saying if you are older than that and
i'm sure you know someone younger
because here's the thing christy
we have to start teaching our young
people how to win
early on in life yeah and so my brand is
making it more attractive and i can say
this with you because we won't be
offended but
i'mma make being debt-free the new cool
sexy thing yeah
you know what i'm saying yeah we're
gonna be debt-free living good
young cool sexy and hips so i love it
that's my but that's your brand i love
it well
so many of you are familiar with my back
story of helping people start side
businesses and small businesses and now
i'm
helping them uh and their faith walk and
in personal development and so if you
have a question for anthony
or for myself give us a call today
triple eight eight two five
five two two five we will get you some
advice and get you pointed in the right
direction all right let's head to the
phones
we've got john in atlanta hey john
what's going on
hey how you all doing good how can we
help
oh it's a little bit of personal finance
question
about six years ago me and my i guess
girlfriend
we're living together now we bought a
house and we're living together we have
kids and
yeah everything and about six years ago
when we first
bought the house the father i guess to
be my father-in-law he uh
gifted us some money to help us out pay
the expenses when we first bought the
house
and shortly like a year and a half later
or about two years later the the
mother-in-law
we had like a little disagreement and
argument all over the phone and
she kind of threw that money on my face
which is clearly gifted by
her husband he knows that's your money
help to help you all out and she just
kind of just threw it on my face and you
know saying
well you know the house is mine you know
because we gave you that money and
all that and now that um i'm well on my
feet i pay the house off i'm completely
debt-free
and i have some money i have about 70
000 money just sitting in the bank right
now and
the way he what he loaned me or gave me
was uh nine thousand
dollars but i wondering should i pay it
back even though he's the one that
gifted it but she's the one that threw
my face and we don't we're not in good
turns with the mother-in-law
uh we just recently found out we're
having our next day expecting another
baby
and um she didn't even tell she's my
wife takes her she didn't even
call her back or nothing and it was just
kind of she's
i guess she really doesn't approve us so
john we're about to go to break let me
let me help you out here real quick
uh do you owe it to her uh no
okay because that that was a gift but if
i was in your shoes
and i'm sitting with some money in the
bank account and i don't want any
headaches
i'm just going to pay mother-in-law off
uh just to just out of love just
out of just just to avoid yeah avoid any
future headaches
because 9 000 is not going to hurt you
and your family you got 70k
sitting in the bank and you're 100 debt
free so if i'm you in your shoes
i would just go in the head and say you
know what i don't owe this to you i'm
going to step
up i'm going to be the bigger person
because me and my wife
and our family we need peace we don't
need drama in our life so
with that being said here you go be
quiet god bless you don't bother us no
more
and bro just don't accept any more gifts
from your mother-in-law or your father
yeah the one thing i would add on to
that john just for your own peace of
mind don't think that paying her back is
going to fix the relationship because
the relationship is broken regardless of
the money
if you want a good relationship it's
going to lead to you're going to have
some conversations
some reconciliation the money's not
going to fix the relationship it'll fix
your peace of mind
but it won't necessarily fix the
relationship that's going to take a lot
more work
that's good this is the ramsay show
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country
or have a better life the army national
guard can help you get there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
slash nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
i'm christy wright ramsay personality
co-hosting with me today is anthony
o'neil fellow ramsey personality we are
both
best-selling authors we both love
helping people in their life and with
their money
and we're taking your calls so give us a
call eight eight two five
five two two five whether it's about
money
business or life we are here for you all
right we've got
austin in portland hey austin how's it
going
pretty good how about yourself good what
can anthony and i do to help you
yeah so so pretty much right now i'm
running like a stalemate with my parents
i got a good amount of money uh
in the bank and i want to invest it uh i
do have some invested in uh some
moderately aggressive mutual funds i
want to put more in
my parents say i should stay for college
because i think i'll need the money for
tuition so
what do you guys think i should do
should i get them on my side listen to
them or
what do you think it sounds like your
parents know something
that you don't which is they expect you
to pay for some college tell us a little
bit more about those conversations and
and what your college plans are
yeah so i've gotten a pretty good
scholarship at school
i still have to pay a little bit out of
pocket nothing crazy um
but i do work a ton i don't make
pointless purchases so i'm
i want to get more money into you know
mutual funds or something get a
retirement fund started something like
that
um and they don't really want me to
right now because they do know that i'll
have to pay
some for school but i'm making enough
that i can pay as i'm going
so i want to take that extra money and
you know invest it how much do you have
uh in cash i have thirty thousand and
mutual funds i have just over like 80
500. okay and what's your income right
now when you said you're working a ton
what's your income and
and what will it be if you even know
when you when you're going to school are
you still planning to work and that kind
of thing
um so i work whenever i'm not at school
and i
anywhere from 10 to 12 000 a year okay
well i'm gonna let ao take this one but
i will say that to have a
savings when you go into this
transitional stage of life is smart
um so your parents are wise in that
aspect now you may not need to save all
that
uh for going into college and especially
with your plan to work and your
scholarships and all that
but but you do need something to fall
back on in case you have an emergency ao
how do you help teenagers that i mean
what a great question first of all
austin the fact that you're asking the
question is awesome
i mean let's call this out austin you
have 30 000 in savings so
clearly you are a bright young man so i
want to start off with that
yeah your future your mutual funds of 8
500
are those covered um in a retirement
plan or is it just in some simple mutual
funds
it's just some simple mutual funds
however my financial advisor does
want to move me into a roth ira in the
next coming months
okay um cool so that's the next step how
much do you want to put more on
cool great um you say you have some
scholarships so how much over the four
years do you need to come up with to
graduate debt-free like what's your
out-of-pocket cost
um so actually i'm in a five-year degree
but i'm in my fourth semester right now
so i have six semesters left and i pay
about 7 500
per semester okay so we're looking at 7
500 per semester
times that by uh four correct
six six so 7 500 times
six so you need 45k just to graduate
college 100
debt free um and so let me help you
understand this one i
i love the fact that you have the energy
and the drive to start investing
i mean to really start building some
wealth i love that and i want you to
keep that
but let me tell you the what's the
number one wealth builder uh blocker for
young people your age is debt
student loans man specifically and so
what your parents are telling you right
now is very wise they're saying hey
use this money to cash flow your way
through school
and here's the thing bro if you graduate
with forty thousand dollars in your
savings
account at 22 21 years old
you can take that money over to a
financial advisor and get that properly
invested
and you still will be ahead of the game
okay a study just came out recently that
uh nearly 58 of the people in america
today don't even have 300
in their savings account you have 30 000
okay
so you are already far ahead of the game
let's keep you far ahead of the game by
avoiding taking out student loans so i
know you're saying hey but anthony i
i can work no here's the thing life
could happen
and so you don't want life to happen and
then you would have had the money
no keep the money in the savings account
just in case you're going to use it
for paying off school if you do not use
it to pay off school you graduate debt
free
still with the money in account go
highlight your financial advisor
and boom uh invest it but going ahead
and get that 8 500
switched over to a roth ira right now
before you start putting more into it so
that way you can get the compound
interest
um and in the way you're moving right
now man within the next
uh christy 20 30 years man this young
kid would be a millionaire just by
investing and saving up properly oh it's
amazing too but i think the good thing
to call out the fact that he's asking
this question is impressive he's going
to be fine he's got 30 000 in the bank
and he's asking this question
the thing that i want people to remember
that are in these uh this age group that
you love to help ao from teenager to
your mid-30s
you are in most cases in a transitional
stage of
life you're talking about college maybe
uh
secondary degrees you're talking about
buying your first home probably
having babies getting married honeymoon
these things cost money
so if you have cash we want you to hold
on to that savings
for any of those upcoming expenses that
you may need that you can't see right
now
and then when that season has passed you
or when you're able to cash flow you
have the extra for sure
talk about investing but that's the
reason the baby steps go in the order
that they do
because we want to protect you
especially those of you that are
listening that are young
we want to help you during those life
stages when you've got those big
expenses coming
up all right we've got a call from kim
in tampa florida hey tim
kim how's it going hey it's going very
well thanks for taking my call i have a
question about entrepreneurship
okay so i'm going to name off six things
because i'm
you know a rockstar announcement and
it's just really challenging
to kind of find out um what direction to
go
as an entrepreneur because i do have a
nine to five okay these are your six
ideas is that what you're about to give
me
yeah all right let's shoot through them
quick what have you got okay
so i've been low-key mentoring since
high school
i was an administrative person when i
was in the in the military
um i did title acquisition which is
recruiting and you know killed it and
you know had awards right now currently
i'm a program manager
and i have a weekly talk show and plus i
love
networking i connect people all the time
that do stuff
so i mean that
you know that's a whole basket full of
stuff it sure is
let's let's back up for just a second
kim first of all i want to commend you
on your confidence
because you are excited and you believe
in yourself and that is the first hurdle
that so many people get stuck at so i'm
impressed with you the second thing is i
love that you
are multi-talented you you have a lot of
talents you have a lot of interest
that's awesome here's what i want you to
think about this is going to be
something that you're not probably going
to have the answer for
in the next couple of minutes but i want
you to think about after we get off the
phone
i want you to think about where you want
to be in five years
10 years what you want this business to
do for you
what you want the money to do for you
what you want your life to look like do
you still want to be working your nine
to five when you start to forecast
out into the future and say here's where
i want to be in five years or here's
what i want where i want to be in seven
years
then you back out of that vision and
you're able to have more clarity about
what you need to do today
you say what must be true today to lead
to that
vision so when you start thinking long
term it's no longer just well what am i
kind of good at and i've done in the
past and what's right in front of me
it's which of these six options and
maybe it's something you didn't even
mention
is going to lead me to where i want to
be in five years so when i ask you that
question is there something that comes
to mind or is that something you need to
think about a little bit
definitely have to think about it yeah
well here's the good thing kim
it just gives you a strategy for
narrowing down your options
i don't want you to think short term
unless your goal is hey
i need to pay off some debt i need cash
fast then you start to look at those six
options and you say which one's going to
make cash the fastest
that answers your question but if you're
thinking this is just fun
i want to use my gifts i want to quit my
nine to five at some point
i want to think long term i want to you
know get myself to where i'm doing what
i love
every day and it doesn't even feel like
work well then you ask different
questions
you say what am i going to do today
that's going to lead me
to that five-year vision and it's more
long-term thinking it's more long-term
planning and then maybe you come up with
a different answer
you know anthony one of the things that
i tell people all the time when i'm
helping them narrow down
their business ideas because i get this
question all the time yeah i call them
the jane of all trades they've got
they've got so many ideas and they've
got so many talents
i tell them to start with what you have
your skills
your strengths and your stuff yes when
you start with what you have
you make it so much easier on yourself
to win you're not having to get another
degree buy a bunch of equipment learn a
bunch of new skills start with what you
have your skills
your education credentials your
strengths things you're naturally good
at
and your stuff what do you have around
you to work with
when you do that you lower the barrier
to entry into the marketplace and you
make it so much easier on yourself to
win
and make money faster this is
the ranci show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm christy wright hosting today with me
is anthony o'neil you can follow us on
instagram at christyb
wright or at anthony o'neil we love
connecting with you
online and on instagram we are taking
your calls america
eight eight two five five two two five
if you have a question about money
starting or growing a business or just
life maybe you're faced with a tough
decision and you want an outside
perspective we are here to help
give us a call triple eight eight two
five five
two two five now blinds.com 100
satisfaction guarantee means that even
if you mismeasure
or pick the wrong color they will remake
your blinds for free
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run every month
you'll save
even more use the promo code ramsey
to get the best deal today's question
comes from ryan in
fairmont i've been making positive
changes in my life
but my friends still see the old me
how do i get them to change their
opinions of me
ayo i want to hear what you think on
this one and then i want to jump in i'm
curious this is going to be good chrissy
you don't want to hear my opinion i do i
do i do i do let's have it i don't care
what my old
friends think new friends getting new
friends you know
i mean even jesus wasn't accepted by you
know his
friends and his community so um for me
i'm just like hey i'm not going to allow
someone to prevent me from
moving forward if you're going to always
remind me of my past you're going to be
in my past
yeah that's just my philosophy that's
good such a simple but really profound
answer because i think sometimes we feel
bad we feel like oh should i do
something even the question is how do i
get them to change their opinions of me
and man we get this confused so often ao
where we think we can change people how
do i get them how do i get my husband on
board how do i get my
parents or in-laws to behave with their
money how do i get someone to do
something you can't
you can't get people to do something
that they don't want to do
all you can do is be you the new you
the new and improved you if you're going
places making positive changes like you
said ryan
and it's their choice if they want to go
with you yeah and here's the truth let's
be real
some of the decisions in our past have
hurt people
and so some people cannot get over that
hurt and
that is okay for them as long as you
know you are getting better you are
maturing
you are progressing forward and you are
growing
forgive yourself of the decisions you
made in your past and proceed forward if
they cannot do that
and see that you are a new man a new
woman that is their
fault uh it's not yours how many
people are listening right now that have
gone through this same exact experience
when they start
their debt-free journey how many friends
and family are going you're
weird what do you mean you're using
coupons what do you mean you're not
going on vacation what do you mean you
won't go out to dinner with us and they
and they don't understand and they they
make fun of you and they they tell you
you're stupid and they tell you this is
this who is this dave ramsey guy and all
that
but the reality is if you kind of like
you said anthony if you surround
yourself
with people that are modeling what the
like kind of life you want to have
people that are wealthy people that have
great marriages people that are great
parents
then you're going to have this awesome
input and influence of people that are
leading you in the direction you want to
go but i will say one
cool thing you might find for all these
people that
that are from your past or even in your
present reminding you of your past
if you keep just being you and you keep
going places
they'll make fun of you for a while some
of them may drop off some of them
fate may fade into your past some of
them might change their life because of
you yeah
they might stop making fun of you and
say hey can you can i borrow that book
yep hey can i can i can you tell me how
you did that thing i know i made fun of
you but i'm sorry because i really want
what you have
i want that marriage you have i want i
want that family you have i want that uh
wealth that you have whatever that is so
i just uh as an encouragement to you
ryan i love
love the advice of if they're not coming
with you uh don't let that hold you back
but at the same time your light
might just inspire them to change their
lives as well so good
all right we've got a call from
stephanie in louisville kentucky hey
stephanie how's it going
good how can anthony help well so my
husband and i have a unique opportunity
um we live at the end of a cul-de-sac
and on one side is our house
and on the other side is this
undeveloped land that's actually owned
by a land developer that's trying to
put in a bunch of houses there's two
ways to access this place either he can
put in
a half a mile of private road and go in
through the back which is going to be
really expensive for him
or um he can extend the
road that we're on which would be a lot
easier problem is
something like 40 years ago the land
survey are messed up
and um the road is not wide enough or at
least the public area is not wide enough
for him to put in those houses
he needs about 10 feet of the end of our
driveway
and he wants to buy it from us but the
problem is we don't really know how to
come up with a number um if you look at
just
the amount of land and you know how much
land out here is worth and do the
calculation with the square footage just
a couple hundred square feet
it's not very much um but it allows this
guy to
to come and build 25 houses and have
probably a pretty hefty profit um so he
asked us how much
it we should sell he we would sell it
for
um we didn't really know how to come up
with a number other than
you know we thought of the increased
property taxes as our
house goes up in value and um just the
inconvenience of
having construction noise for a year or
two um but is that you know
are there any other factors we should
consider when we're coming up with a
number
um i don't know we've asked on
a contractor that we know um a land
developer that we know and
neither one of them had any idea how to
come up with a number either
yeah stephanie well i'll tell you i
don't know
the details of um even coming up with
the formula for that but i do have two
questions about that
do you want to stay in this house long
term
are you planning to stay there
we're planning on it for at least the
next few years
um we go back and forth about whether
we're going to stay on this particular
piece of property or
um end up going somewhere else and
renting out the house here
yeah and then the next question do you
want them to develop this land do you
want those
those home like what's the implication
of you at the i'm just picturing you at
the end of this sweet little cul-de-sac
and it's so quiet and
secluded and nice and there's going to
be all these houses coming
is this something that you are okay with
to begin with before we even talk about
a number is this something you're okay
with them
taking part of your driveway yeah i
think we are um because we've actually
we own our property and the one next to
it so it's actually like
kind of a large area um that even if
there were houses next door which
most of our street has housed like
duplexes
and we've got quite a bit of land we've
got more land than pretty much any
houses around here
so we'd still be fairly fairly secluded
so um
stephanie have you talked to a realtor
no yeah so if i was you i would talk to
a realtor okay because the realtor can
come out there and do comps in your area
and not really come as far as in the
housing market but he can come out there
and say all right
for this amount of the for this amount
of land at the end of your driveway
we can play around with some numbers
kind of take away some things and he can
throw out a ballpark figure
this is not something that is common uh
but i do know that a realtor can come
out there
okay look at your square footage look at
what you're going to lose on on the land
as far as in part of the acreage of the
home
and he can say okay this or she can say
for this
much this is what is the ballpark figure
so i would definitely reach out to one
of our real estate agents and see and
get them included
into the process because you will have a
contract you will have an agreement
and that real estate agent can help you
negotiate the price
and halt and also help you find more
research on the price
now the the builder the developer is not
going to like that
because they will have to pay some some
type of commission but right now you
need to make sure you have the proper
research and a real estate agent can
help you out with that
and then two you need to have to make
sure you have the proper documentation
to cover you and yourself and your
family
down the road so i would reach out to a
real estate agent and have
uh him or her uh do the research for you
and present those numbers to you
and then for me i'm kind of like dave if
he comes back and says hey it's worth 50
grand i'm gonna tell them i want a
hundred grand
because if they really want it they may
give you 75.
you know and so whatever it is it's
probably less than what their other
option is which is going in the back
side like you said
right the other thing i would add and i
love what anthony said this has been
done before
so you're going to have to do a little
bit of digging a little bit of research
maybe the
contractor you talked to hasn't dealt
with this before but some contractor
somewhere has
absolutely so just keep digging you want
to find people that have gone through
this before
so that you are getting as much
information as possible on your side
to be an advocate for you and take
everything into consideration not just
the
actual square footage the inconvenience
the property tax
everything that goes into it when you
come up with this number and remember
just like anthony said
it's a starting point for a conversation
yeah it doesn't mean it's this hard and
fast number but it's actually going to
protect you in the process
if you do your homework this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
so
i'm christy wright with anthony o'neil
we're taking your calls america about
your life
your money your businesses things you're
working on
things you need help with give us a call
triple eight eight two five
five two two five we got a call from
yashica
in raleigh north carolina hey yashika
how's it going
hi how are you good how can anthony help
thank you so dilemma is i'm currently
when my marriage ended i
moved into a rental and i'm currently
still in that rental
and i guess my question is
if i ultimately know that i'm i want to
build a dream home
like in the near future if i should do
that
even if i would like to do that with a
spout with the intention of remarrying
in the future
so in the meantime do you think it would
be wise to just continue
renting or maybe just buying something
with the intention of selling it or
should i just go ahead and
build the home you know on my own uh
this is a really interesting question
i'm so curious
what anthony has to say about this
because here's my what you're asking is
not really
just a financial question you're asking
about i mean this is a life question and
i'll tell you my
my personal beliefs and this is this is
my personal beliefs i don't want you
to put your life on hold for a potential
spouse that you can't
control the timeline of i mean it'd be
different if you're in a serious
relationship and you're gonna you're
gonna see a ring in the next six months
that's a different conversation
but if if that's not you're not sure
when that's gonna happen
then i don't want you to put your dreams
on hold if you're ready to and have the
money too so let's talk about that like
do you have the
the savings to be able to start working
on this house or is that far off as well
no i'm i'm in a position where i can do
it on my own right now
yeah um if i may ask
you don't have to answer um how old are
you yeshika
i'm 37 37 all right cool are you dating
someone seriously right now
no okay all right all right you have any
kids
i have one daughter she's mine she's not
okay okay okay all right all right all
right
you see i did a video on this and i
all the guys are looking at me like
don't mess up anthony i'm so ready for
this i'm like i am on the edge of my
seat
yeah dream home y'all shake it
no no i don't think you should do it
should you go buy a nice condo or nice
town home
yes you're young you're beautiful you're
bright you're intelligent
i believe your king your your your
provider your man
will find you what i would hate for you
to do
is to build a home again this is
personal beliefs this is not dave ramsey
this is not randy solution it's not
christy right
this is anthony o'neil just saying what
i would say to one of my lady friends or
to my sister
um is go buy you something nice if you
want
you know so that way maybe you can rent
it out down the road when you get
married but to go out there and invest
into your dream
home what i would hate to do is do that
and then you have to leave that dream
home
because your husband is in um you're in
raleigh north carolina you
because your husband's in atlanta uh so
that's just my two cents
buy something but dream huh here we go
here we go let me in here's the thing
one thing i want to call out
and this is this is i would say that a
ao and i might agree on this this part
of it
i don't think that you have just one
dream home
i think you have your idea of your dream
home right now at 37 with your daughter
that you can see
you may have a completely different
version of a dream home when you're 55
and married and so i would i would take
the pressure off that there's only one
dream home for the rest of your life
that's a lot of pressure and a lot of
commitment
55 is a long ways away though can her
dream home be different at 40
yes well that's what i'm saying like
take the pressure off
that you have to have your dream home
only one time in your life
and so you can't have it now because you
want to have it with your spouse
i would say you may have a dream home
now that's like this is right for me
right now
and then in three years you get married
and you all have a new dream
and it's in atlanta or it's somewhere
else and you have the right to change
your mind
change your plans change your dreams
change your house
and that's okay and the thing that i
would add and this is this is fun
because we don't agree and that's fine
i don't think you need you don't need to
settle for a townhouse yashica
you don't need a man to have a dream
house you don't need a condo
you can have a house if you got the
money and you want to build a house
small house
medium house whatever kind of house you
want you don't need to settle for a town
house
why does a single woman or even a single
man like myself need a big old home
paying all these light bills paying all
these different things kristy
you know you're telling people about how
to secure the bag this isn't based on
need this is what
if she has the money she has the right
to have what she wants do you need it
i don't need half my earrings but i
wanna
okay why does she have to wait on a man
i love this conversation we're just
gonna camp here what time do we have to
be out
why does she have to wait on a man to
have her dream house what if he never
comes
kristy what i'm saying i'm not saying
america that she has to wait on a man
i'm just simply saying hey while you are
young and single continue securing the
bag
it lives somewhere nice is the town on
the bag
i mean she's going to secure the bag by
getting something that doesn't have a
lot of electricity
a large electricity bill a large you
know
overhead for so that way when she gets
married again chrissy watch this
she's coming to the table with a lot
more to say hey i want to build this
but i'm not just coming saying you have
to do it i've been praying i've been a
good steward and here is
200 000 go towards this dream home
because if she goes and she does that
right now
christy again my personal opinion she's
not coming to the table with that kind
of bag
she's going to come with hey i have my
dream home i have this large mortgage
you moving in with me or you're doing
this rather than it's like hey
i've been praying i've been faithful i
bought a nice town home or i bought a
nice small home for me and my kid
um but it wasn't the ultimate dream home
and maybe i could be off because when i
hear dream home
i hear something differently from myself
you know i hear i hear a big home yeah
and i could be wrong okay no no let's
just let's say you're right let's say
that that's fine
let's say i believe that yashica is
going to get married again i do too
but what if she doesn't or what if or
what if that's 10 years from now and
then she
waited 10 years for a man in a town
house no yeah
i'm not i'm not saying wait 10 years i'm
saying give it to 40.
i think she'll find a man this i think a
man will find her this year he will
love her love her daughter get married
by the end of next year and they can
dream off together
i would tell my little sister to do that
and she did just that she stayed with my
parents
she met my brother-in-law glenn and now
they are
multi successful millionaires doing
great things
totally totally it's just it's just i
would say it's not mutually exclusive
that you have to not have
a house not build your house uh or
have a successful marriage i think i
think you can do both right i totally
agree
and i'm going to just buy out on this
one you got options
hey and i have given you options that's
what we're here we're here for you
on the ramsay show to give you options i
believe you'll get married and i think
you'll do what's right for you
and uh it's a fun conversation though
because it's not just a money
conversation it's a values conversation
uh that we're talking about this is hey
take a second to explain to people what
securing the bag means
yeah let's for everybody listening that
is
like me and when i say people i mean me
what secure the bag is
the producer wants to tell people what
secure the vaccinations what secure the
bad means secure the bag because
some of y'all are probably wondering
what in the world is going on for you
everyone is
not just some people james and madison
um and everyone in studio and america
securing the badge just simply means
that you're you're making money
you're getting money you're saving money
and so that's just a new hip
term a moral cool and relevant term for
making money
saving money uh flipping money just
really
getting more money is it um is that
different than building wealth or are
those kind of the same thing it's the
same thing you know what i'm saying i
mean building wealth is you know you
know what
that definition is and securing the bag
it's just something that the hip hop
generation has added to that term you
know you get a bag
secure a bag and secure the bag simply
means get the money and you
keep the money yeah you're not getting
the money and going out there and
spending it
yeah you're you're making money you're
saving it you're investing it you're
building true wealth
i'm so sorry america i'm sorry james for
you know confusing y'all
actually i didn't bring that one up this
time christie did
i did my sister from another mother
she needs to wait we need to know what
we're waiting with but i think it's good
i think this is a really important
conversation because the reality is
yashica is not the only person dealing
with this situation of going
i have dreams for my life some of it it
may be a baby it may be a different job
maybe something else
some of those dreams i can control the
timeline of a lot of them i can't
yeah so how do i make decisions today
with the money i have
based on what i know and the make the
best decision
for me this is a good conversation oh
great and we should follow up on this we
should
in america i did not say she should i
just said she had to
i just said she should okay all right
that's what makes it that's clear
i want to thank producer james child
associate producer kelly daniel
and you america for listening this puts
the first hour
in the books this is the ramsey show
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world
subscribe or follow today wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car
rental studio this is the ramsey show
where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life
and your money i'm christy wright i'm a
business coach i'm an author and
ramsay personality you can follow me on
instagram at christybright and hosting
with me today
is my good friend also author fellow
ramsay personality anthony o'neal
you can follow him on instagram anthony
o'neil we've had a fun
first hour and we are just going to
continue the fun give us a call triple
eight
eight two five five two two five we're
answering your calls
about money about business whether it's
a small business
side business side gig maybe you just
need some extra cash to pay off your
debt
i can help you with that or just life
you've got some questions about a
decision you're facing and want an
outside perspective we are here for you
aaa 825-5225 we're gonna go to nicole in
dallas texas hey nicole how's it going
hi guys how are you great what's going
on
so i have a couple questions um this is
in regards to
the most recent stimulus checks and my
student loans
so i have been doing the dave ramsey
plan following the principles
explicitly and i have paid off forty
four thousand dollars
all in 2020 with my fiance and i just
killing it wow congratulations well we
have
thank you all we have left is my student
loans
and that is sitting at thirty one
thousand
sixty six dollars and a pesky 56 cents
they are currently not due
but i really want to start attacking
them
and some other things that are kind of
in our mix is my fiancee's car
his transmission went out so we are
functioning as a one car family
which is a blessing because we're both
working from home secondly we want to
start saving for
a wedding and we also want to save for a
house
so we are praying through this
and prioritizing but i really want to
get down to the nitty-gritty i want to
attack my student loans
in the best way possible and i already
have it built
in the every dollar app so it's already
set up with the interest rate
it's already going from smallest to
largest
i'm just ready to go on this and
i'm basically sitting at where they're
not
due so i can get pretty creative with my
payments
and pay specific loans off but october
2021 is when they all go active and they
all go
due at the same time
uh when is the wedding nicole so we
actually got engaged
before coped and kind of before the
world
got quiet um and we've actually we've
done a little bit of planning
and we don't have a date yet because um
i come from a large italian family and i
want my family to be present and i want
it to be
joyful and i just don't really want the
coveted
you know little your sadness following
us with
that so and we want to be respectful as
well to our family members and make sure
that it's a safe environment for
everybody so we just haven't picked a
date yet
okay um i'm gonna give you i'm gonna
give you two
two answers one of them you may not
receive it and that's fine i just want
to give it to you put it out there
uh because i love you i don't know you
but i love you and then the other answer
let me give it a practical thing
of your question um here's the the first
answer that i want to say
you guys are already living together um
you're already
acting like you're married you already
have combined your finances which i'm
not a huge fan
of um non-married people doing and so my
suggestion is only because i just i love
you and i don't want to see y'all win
um and with my my particular christian
faith background
um you know i'm not perfect but i
definitely got to say this
um i would definitely say how about
y'all just go ahead and just save this
1400
put that towards getting married just go
ahead and get married maybe a small
wedding
because covet we don't know when covert
is going away
and so um yeah i don't want i don't want
to see you all
living as an engaged couple doing
everything as a married couple for the
next two three years just going ahead
and get a small
small wedding go down to the courthouse
do something private
you know and then when covet is is
lifted and you and your family
feel like it's safe to um to do it
uh they have a maybe a bigger wedding or
a bigger celebration of y'all's union
um that would be the first thing i would
do with the 1400
i want to jump in on that before you go
into the tactical ao because i i really
agree especially in this world and
you're seeing a lot of brides go through
this
yeah um engaged couples go through this
and the idea of when it is quote unquote
safe
is a moving target and i'm not this is
not a political statement this is just
like if
if you're going to get married someday
some day is not a day on the calendar
and it's it's just going to get pushed
out and pushed out and pushed out you're
not prioritizing something that is
sacred and i hear in your voice it's
sacred to you you want your family there
but you know uh just like you said
anthony my sister-in-law did that last
year she had they had a small
backyard wedding and they got married
and it cost hardly anything i think it
was just in the backyard with just
family and friends
and then they had a big celebration
reception
in the fall you could do your big
italian reception whenever you feel
comfortable with that
but then you're prioritizing your
marriage um in this grand scheme i just
wanted to jump in and affirmations i
think that's really good advice
go ahead with the the tactical too yeah
and nicole it's not i heard you want to
talk earlier so i definitely give you
some time to respond but uh
just know me and christy are not
attacking which is we just want to give
you some practical advice my brother
did the very same thing john gibbs he
got married right in the middle of
kovitt
and um had a very small wedding because
he didn't want to wait so long and he'd
want to live with his wife just acting
as a
married couple but they're not married
so that's what i would do the first
fourteen hundred dollars with
um i would go ahead and get married if i
was in your shoes just to go ahead and
just
seal that and then from there uh move on
um and then it'll say if you don't take
that advice because that's totally up to
you
so then yes the very first thing i'm
going to tell you to do
is attack your student loans okay go
ahead and just pay it
uh towards your student loan so this way
you can get ahead of
uh any interest that will come up in
october when it's time to pay back uh
the student loans so that's what i would
do with the 1400
if you don't decide to get married go
ahead and apply it to your
student loans does that help nicole
awesome
absolutely thank you guys for that
perspective because honestly
i just have been so zeroed in i'm he's
kind of the free spirit i'm a nerd and
i've been so honed in on these
student loans and actually his folks had
a time
share up in montana and two weekends ago
we kind of dabbled in an elopement up
there so
we might have to have a little um
financial meeting tonight in regards to
a little small wedding because that is
just
so cool and i didn't even think about
that you know
and you know what nicole if you do it i
want you to call back to the show and
tell them that
tell anthony we got married and if you
all do that i'm going to send you all a
gift a financial gift
uh just because i believe that's
something you should be doing for real
that's awesome well nicole great great
call thanks so much for your question
and you know what this is this is an
exciting time you're talking about big
plans you're talking about big dreams
this is a
this is an exciting thing and i love
this reminder
that she can prioritize her marriage and
still attack those student loans it
doesn't mean the student loans aren't
going to get attacked it doesn't mean
your financial goals are off track
we're just going to zoom out a little
bit and have the right perspective and
say
hey what's most important right now this
is most important
and we're going to do this we're still
going to have the big italian
celebration at some point
and we're still going to attack the
student loans we're just going to do
things in the right
order great question this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
so
[Music]
well st patrick's day brought us a
little luck this year the irs announced
that it's pushing the federal tax
deadline back
everyone in the u.s now automatically
gets an
extra month to file with the date moved
from april 15th
to may 17th why well the pandemic's
still affecting things and when you
throw in the very recent tax changes
the april 15th deadline was looking like
a pretty tall order
now with the change to may 17th you have
an extra month
not just to file but also to pay your
tax bill
if you're in texas oklahoma or louisiana
your tax date from the irs is still june
15th
because of the winter storms so what
does this all mean
well you have extra time to do your
taxes but if you can
file now especially if you're due for a
refund go ahead and do it and that
advice comes straight from the irs
and if you need help filing either
online or with a trusted tax advisor
we can help text tax tax
to three three seven eight nine and get
it done that's
tax to three three seven eight
nine all right we're gonna keep going to
the phones and we've got adriana in
ventura california
hey adriana how's it going hi good how
are you guys
good how can we help um
so i'm coming because i have 130
000 in savings and i wanted to know if i
should buy a home with that or put it
towards my current mortgage
what what are your plans i mean aside
from the money what are your plans are
you
are you planning to move do you need to
move no i don't need to move
um so the reason why i'm considering
this is because i'm in a special
situation where
the home that i want to buy it was um
my sister uh my sisters and i um it was
our
it's our home it's 50 50 and so she
wants to get rid of
her 50 percent and in order to
um to um
if we sell it because he was rented for
10 years we would have to pay
appreciation or
what is it called um
oh no um we don't appreciate it
so we will have to pay taxes
yeah so this is not the home you're
living in you're saying the home that
you're living in is not the one that you
and your sister own together
yeah correct no no i have my family home
yeah
i have a my my own house with my husband
um yeah here's the thing um
i'm going to say sell the home i'm going
to say
both of you all just go ahead and just
sell the home and then just stay where
you are
take that 130 as long as you are debt
free as long as you have a fully funded
emergency fund
take that 130 000 and go ahead and just
put it on top of
uh your current mortgage just go ahead
and sell your 50 percent she sells her
50
and just get out of it because it sounds
like maybe it was inherited or
something happened and they inherited
the home and so i would just sell the 50
get get rid of that responsibility pay
off my current mortgage
and then proceed forward yeah and it's
interesting too because i can't tell you
how many times we've gotten calls like
this on the ramsey show anthony where
people are in a situation and they're
doing something and they are considering
to continue to do it just because
they've done it yes not because it's in
line with their goals
where they want to go it's necessarily
the right thing anymore something that
was right 10 years ago isn't right
anymore or in your
in your example if it's something you
inherited not necessarily something you
wanted
and so i love that advice it's it's just
get that out of your hair
yes you'll have to pay taxes on it but
then you also still have all that extra
money from the sale of it you can put
your current mortgage mortgage you're
going to be in a great financial
situation and
you just don't have to deal with it
anymore if that's not a part of your
ongoing plan financial plan
gets you out of this tangled thing with
your sister which would be good as well
so that's a
great advice all right let's go to
catherine in philadelphia hey catherine
how's it going
pretty good how are you good what's
going on
um so i have kind of a specific question
about
taking some time off work to do like a
long through hike onto the appalachian
trail
okay well what's what's the situation
around it
um so i don't have some money to save
them i'm on i guess i'm technically on
baby step
seven i don't have any kids or a house
um
and then i have about forty thousand
save which is my emergency fund and then
also money that i would use towards it
um
how much so i just kind of was looking
for some advice how much extra do you
have on top of your emergency fund
uh that is the 40k is everything
and then my 401k i'm being a 401k all
right sounds good what do you do
oh i'm an engineer okay how old are you
catherine
i'm 20 32 oh 32
yes okay all right um
should you take six months off to go
hiking
i am so excited about this answer i
can't even see straight because i feel
like there's going to be another
really good segment between me and you
because let me tell you catherine
ayo and i don't have the same answer on
this question i can just tell you
right now i can tell you right now go on
give her your answer
and then we'll go together but see
here's the thing we might
be we might be on the same page okay
let's have it because she's debt-free
she doesn't have any you know she has a
fully funded emergency fund
here's where i have a question that will
determine my answer
uh catherine how much do you need for
six months to live like how much how
much will you have to spend
um on your bills back at home and to
survive
how much money will you need uh
probably 8k and that's probably
overestimating so about ten thousand
dollars worst case
absolute worst case scenario yeah that
leaves you thirty thousand dollars
in your bank account yes at 30 something
years old how much do you have in your
retirement account right now
120 000 go hiking yes
yes see i'm so excited i didn't expect
that catherine i thought i was gonna
have to swoop in
all y'all out there laughing y'all just
see y'all was like anthony don't do it
he said anthony said should you take
six months off to go hiking i was like
oh this is not gonna be good for
catherine
tell me how he repeated the question he
doesn't like hiking and he doesn't like
this place
i do not like hiking but at the same
time that's why we work so hard do what
we have to do so we can one day do what
we want to do
that's right live like no one else like
dave says so we can
live like no one else and so she's done
that part
go live now she would have said quit
working for the rest of her life
christie
i would be like nah listen here's here's
my perspective that i'm bringing to this
too
catherine as a mom of three kids go
hiking sister
go go hiking if you want if you have
kids in your future lord willing if
that's part of your plan now
is the time now is the time to live
those dreams
before you got kids so go hiking and
that's christian that's as long as she's
saying
10 grand yeah i'm saying that 10 grand
we don't have a lot of needs out in the
woods ayo there's not a lot of things to
spend money
so what's she going to do get rid of our
apartment and stuff back here too
no but i'm saying the 10 grand covering
the bills there's not a lot of
additional expenses it's not like we're
going to travel europe for six months
but that's going to be really expensive
so
the woods are the woods are cheap so i
love it catherine do it and when you do
call in and tell ao how it is maybe
we'll get him out in the woods get him
hiking all right
we got a call from matthew in richmond
hey matthew how's it going
hey going well how you guys doing good
how can anthony and i help
yeah good um i got my wife in the
background but our question
is are we financially ready to uh
start our own or my own consulting
business all right let's have some
details what do you currently do how
much money do you have let's talk about
that
sure so we've uh kind of streamlined
what we're doing i'm a civil engineer
uh actually quit my job making um
around 130 000 a year and my wife
is now she's a freelancer does film
film work and she can make pretty good
money but it's
you know temporary work from you know a
couple months at a time are you
debt-free um
we are debt-free and how much savings do
you
we have 24 000 in an emergency fund and
then we have a down payment of about 160
000.
all right we got to wrap this up because
we got to go to break here's what i'm
going to tell you you need to have
three to six months of expenses ready
to get this consulting business off the
ground and you need a secure
plan on how you're going to monetize it
and make it profitable very quickly you
need the money there to support you as
you transition into this business
not hope it's just going to magically be
there but you need a plan for it to be
there
and it needs to be a proven plan with
clients with leads that kind of plan
uh you have that there then yes you're
ready but if not you may need to save up
a little bit more to get it ready before
you're ready to take that next step
great question this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm christy wright co-hosting me with me
today is anthony o'neil my good friend
and fellow ramsay personality and we're
taking your calls
about life business and of course money
you can give us a call at triple eight
eight two
five five two two five and this has been
fun today because some of the calls
anthony and i have different answers on
which leads to a really good discussion
i've already been seeing people comment
on instagram which is really fun you can
follow me at christy b wright and
anthony
anthony o'neill and we love connecting
with you we love hearing your stories
we love answering your questions all
right we're going to go to the phones
we've got a call from rob in atlanta
georgia hey rob how's it going
hey chrissy ayo how are you guys great
what's up
i was calling to see i have money left
over from the 529 plan from my daughter
and i was wondering if i could change
the beneficiary to my son-in-law
uh he has student loan debt and
help them move forward okay are they
legally married
they are engaged and they get married in
august certainly i wouldn't do anything
until then
yeah yeah so once they are legally
married you can transfer
your daughter can transfer the 529
that's in her name
to her spouse or to her kids um and so
from there
then from there the max that they can
take out is ten thousand dollars
um a year and so um yes but they have to
be legally married
and she only can transfer to her son i
mean to her kids
or to her legally married spouse uh so
yes you can perf perfect
all right awesome thanks for calling
great question man
you know it's hard with some of these uh
ever-changing rules and some of the fine
print i'm not good with fine print ao so
it's it's good to
i'm glad you know stuff like that
because i wouldn't have known that
either all right we've got a call from
dineen in
boston hey janine how's it going great
how are you
good how can anthony and i help okay
great thank you for having me so my
question is about goals
i met someone recently who asked the
question what are your goals
and for their life and don't tell me
about helping other people what are you
doing specifically for yourself
i struggled to answer that question
because i'm i guess i have a passion for
helping other people and making them
great
and so i kind of wanted some advice um
or recommendations on how to refocus
back
on myself and trying to make him look
great
that's an interesting question and i'm
curious what anthony thinks on this i
would say that
um first i just kind of want to back out
of that and not look at goals as
something that are self-serving
or selfless that goals are really a tool
they're really a strategy
to get you to where you want to be yeah
so where you want to be could be helping
others where you want to be could be
doing something for yourself or growing
yourself financially or
losing weight or running a marathon or
starting a business i mean it could be
whatever end
goal that your end finish line that you
want to define
for yourself and your life and where you
want to be in your future
and that could be six months from now a
year from now 10 years from now
a goal is really just your tool to get
you there and so that becomes your
your path to say okay here's my strategy
of of how much you know for example in
weight loss i want to lose 50 pounds
okay i need to lose five pounds a week
you know
five pounds a month or whatever your
path is between here and there depending
on your timeline so i would
i would start by asking you where do you
want to be not what should you do
today but where do you want to be
because when you cast your vision out
into the future
you begin to see what you want your life
to look like and if you're not careful
deneen one of the things i've done
before and i know a lot of people that
have done this
if you don't define what your finish
line is you'll end up crossing someone
else's finish line
i remember being in a small group one
time anthony where um we were all
sharing what we our goals were for the
year and this this guy next to me shares
and he said um i've got a goal to read
30 books this year and i thought oh
that sounds fun i should read 30 books
this year that was a terrible goal for
me with two
you know young kids under the age of
three so so think for yourself where do
you want to be
what is your version of success what do
you want your future to look like
and then you basically use goals to get
you there so i would start with that
question where do you want to be
in a year janine you know where do you
want to be in two years or three years
what what excites you what are you
dreaming about for the future let's
start with that question
okay that's a great question too um so
i really kind of have a passion for
helping
people help helping people
um that probably sounds amazing but what
i mean is just like
overcome brokenness so there was a time
in my life like
to mentor survivors of human sex
trafficking and
i was passionate about that then some
things happened in my life so it kind of
pushed me a little bit away from
focusing on it but i
it just felt good it felt right and
helping other people realize that they
have like worth and value
and they can overcome whatever they've
been through
um so
i guess it's kind of big you know i want
to help
build communities and eventually get
into
like philanthropy um that's kind of
kind of where i am right now that's
great and here's the opposite of what i
do right now
what do you do right now i'm in the
military
okay well thank you for your service i i
don't think it's a bad thing at all that
it's vague i just want to encourage you
you know when i help women
through business boutique at the event
or even back whenever uh through the
business boutique podcast anthony we
start with
and we do this through entre leadership
too we start with a dream
and a dream is fuzzy it's kind of like i
don't know i just i want to help people
heal
and build communities and it feels
really vague and it feels fuzzy and
that's what dreams are we can't quite
put our finger on him yet that's okay
that's what a dream is but as you back
out of that dream and say okay
what does a vision for that dream look
like well vision gets more specific
okay in five years i have started a
nonprofit or i have become a volunteer
or a leader in a nonprofit that is
helping human trafficking victims and i
am helping through counseling and
consulting you get more specific with
the vision
and then out of the vision you back out
of that further and say okay what's the
goal
to get me to that vision that fulfills
that dream and so
danine i just want to encourage you to
keep working on that process
you've got the dream you've got this
high level
kind of fuzzy idea of maybe sort of what
you want to do but you're not sure what
it looks like
i would just continue to spend time with
that dream journal about it
pray about it think about all the ways
that you could engage with that there's
so many different ways that you could do
exactly what you just said and so what
are your strengths
what excites you what's realistic with
your stage of life with your skills and
and your education and your time
restraints maybe with a full-time job or
something else you have going on
but start with that dream spend time
with it and back out of it
and put a little bit more clarity and
more specifics around it for a vision
and then back out of that and set goals
that
get you there and danine if you'll stay
on the line i would love to send you a
copy of my book
business boutique even though it's for
women starting and growing businesses it
can help you
even with this i dream with this idea
and the first
few chapters talk about this exact
process i just walked you through in
much more detail
going from dream to vision to goals and
so you can even just go through those
first few chapters
and that'll help you get clarity around
what your goals should be and what that
can look like for your life but i'm
excited for you that's a great question
and i think it's awesome that you want
to help others and i don't think that's
a bad thing at all they're not mutually
exclusive
you know anthony i think people have
this idea that when we do things
in life it can be through our career or
something else you know even on the side
just
hobbies it either is
selfless or selfish it's either
self-serving
or completely uh for others and
and these are not mutually exclusive i
tell people all the time business is a
win-win
it's a win for the marketplace when you
serve the marketplace and it's a win for
you when you earn an income
for your family so where do you think
this idea comes from because i know you
talk about this even on your show
that it's either for others or for me it
can't be both and if it's for me then
i'm a bad person
and if it's for others it's like we
can't even consider yourself in the
process
i mean i think it comes from the
generation of being uh
well the culture says if if it doesn't
help someone else then you're selfish
but then if you're helping someone else
then you're not you don't really care
about yourself
so i think for me people are just
confused and i'm like you it's it's okay
to do both
if i start a business it's benefiting me
personally
right because it's bringing income into
my home and it's helping me build
wealth while at the same time serving my
community
helping other people and so um i
definitely think that you need to find
something that helps out with both
and when i look at goals goes to me i
had it on my notepad i pulled up earlier
because i've been writing down some
things from my books but goals are about
the results we want to achieve
now habits are about the processes that
leads to those results
so you got to have goals but you got to
have daily habits
to accomplish your goals yeah the
discipline
this one craig gerstell says it's the
small things behind the scenes
that no one sees that lead to the big
things
that everyone wants it's those small
things behind the scenes
those disciplines those daily habits
that lead to those goals
and those visions so good this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
i'm christy wright sitting in today with
anthony o'neil we are
both here to answer your questions about
life
money or business and we've got a lot of
exciting things we're working on anthony
has
the table his new podcast where he
tackles
all types of tough issues fun
conversations real world
relatable topics i have the christy
wright show a new episode airs every
tuesday
and i haven't talked about it today but
wanted you guys to know that my new
devotional is out now
it's called living true 40 days to get
back to you
this is a 40 day devotional specifically
to help you get back to yourself i don't
know if you've ever felt like that but i
have
tough seasons of life or um in your
job certainly in my role as a mom it's
different things can lead you to that
result
but the sentiment is the same i just
feel like i've lost myself
man coven made people feel like that
absolutely i feel like um
you know this anthony from working at
this company and and we launched
projects and you have timelines and you
get excited this was supposed to release
in april of 2020 got pushed back got
pushed back
and god knew when it needed to be out
there and i think it was right when
people were starting to feel that of man
i feel like i've lost myself what is
going on in this world
and i'm going to walk you through four
sections of knowing who god is
who you are where you are in your season
of life and where you're going and what
god says about your future
wow and uh it's just a it's an awesome
three to four
minute daily devotional to get you some
time with god
some time to get back to you that's
living true 40 days to get back to you
would love to hear what you guys think
if you have checked it out and if you're
a man listening it's a great gift for
your wife we hear a lot that a lot that
uh men are buying it for their wives or
girlfriends or moms or daughters
all right we're gonna go to the phones
we've got chris calling in from
washington d.c
hey chris how's it going hey y'all how
you doing
great what's your question for us all
right great great
uh just uh my wife and i just had our
first
anniversary uh last week congratulations
made it through pandemic and uh intact
yeah but yeah we're both uh
we're both in our mid-30s we're in baby
step four
um bought a home in 2019
and we're you know really thinking
seriously about a kitchen
remodel um you know and those are pretty
pricey especially in this area
uh but we live in a town home
likely to cost around 25 to 30k for the
remodel
we've actually got 30k saved
i guess my question is is really trying
to figure out if we're about to do
something dumb
by um you know investing in a remodel
versus waiting
until later and just really trying to
figure out
um if there's any guidance that you all
have in terms of making that decision
is that 30 000 that you have is that all
that you have or that's
above and beyond your emergency fund
yeah that's above and beyond uh
specifically for
house improvement or home improvement
okay one more question for you chris
the um quote that you've gotten on a
kitchen remodel of 25 to 30.
have you gotten actual quotes on that or
is that just a wet finger in the air
guess
uh no we've had about three to four
estimates and so it's really about
trying to narrow
you know narrow it down and make a
decision and pull in the trigger
yeah it's just a lot of money we're
trying to figure out if we should
actually do it or not
how much is in your emergency fund man
um
we have uh we usually carry about six
months i mean it's about 19
five right now and you're in washington
dc
that's correct yeah i need you to update
a little bit
yeah i would definitely say about 25 in
washington dc
then you'll come down to about 25 000
for the remodel
and here's my philosophy when it comes
for remodeling um
i'm going to wait until i can afford to
pay for it twice
while i'm waiting watch this i'm going
to get several
quotes from other people to see
um if i could find a better deal right
now with everything housing market being
with the way it is
a lot of people are trying to remodel
prices are going
sky high prices are crazy right now you
know and so if i was you
i would up my emergency fund especially
being in washington dc to at least 25k
and then from there you have 25k in your
savings account i would spend the next
six months or next three months uh
trying to get that to about 50k for
remodeling
find you something to do for 20 000 then
you can maybe use the other 30 000
to do some other stuff around the house
but just my personal philosophy is
i'm going to wait for any kind of
remodeling until i can afford to pay for
it twice when i get that number i'm
going to do a lot of research i'm going
to interview at least five different
people
once they interview those five different
people i'm gonna see which one comes
about the lowest route then i'm gonna
pay cash for it
um as the journey goes on that's just
that's just my two cents brother but i
would definitely up your
because washington dc is expensive it's
expensive and i like your i like that
advice anthony of pay for it twice
because even if you don't need it you
have it
and house remodeling projects anybody
that's ever done them knows
they always take twice as much and cost
and take twice as long yes
twice as much money twice as much time
and and that becomes a major headache if
you don't have it so you definitely i
love that advice that's really good the
other thing i would throw in there chris
i think you said that um you guys are
newly married
just take into consideration anything
else
that may be more important next year
that you'd rather have that money for i
don't know if you guys are planning to
start a family
or anything else uh i don't know how you
know how stable your jobs are but just
before you spend that money on a kitchen
remodel which is not a bad thing
yeah but make sure that that's more
important
than like a nursery in two or three
years if you want to do that so just it
changes i mean it just changes your
your perspective when you think about
all the things coming down the line
yeah and then maybe the kitchen remodel
still happens but maybe it
just happens in a different priority
order than you originally had planned
when it comes to remodeling at home we
know the top the number one is the
kitchen ladies look at the kitchen when
they first walk in is the kitchen big
enough is it nice enough then the master
bedroom
and then it's out then after that's the
official wet living room space so
chris to make that investment is a wise
investment
to do for a home building process but
just make sure financially is right
because let's say if you get a quote for
twenty thousand dollars i can almost
guarantee you you're gonna
end up spending thirty thousand dollars
and so what i don't want you to do is
have the money
right on the head and then now you gotta
go into your emergency fund
to finish this project that's another
reason why i say make sure you can
afford to pay for it twice
you have some extra left over and then
get some better quotes
yeah and it's for two reasons too it's
not only because you don't want to be
stressed if it costs more
it's also they may get in there and
you're like hey it would only be an
extra
2 000 to to open up this wall and it
makes the whole room and you're like oh
well while we're in here we want to do
that
yes and if you had the money you'd want
to do it and you just don't want to be
right on the line
like that that's a great um great
perspective you know when anthony when
my husband and i bought our house
it was about eight years ago we didn't
have kids we'd been married a year
and it was an older house it is an older
house it was built in 83.
there was a lot of stuff we wanted to do
but we prioritized it
based on what i was saying with the kids
so for example the laundry room and
those old houses opened up to the
kitchen it was in the kitchen basically
i was like i can just visualize
hampers everywhere with kids clothes and
so we turned that into a pantry
built a laundry room upstairs later
years later built on the deck we wanted
but we didn't do the deck
first no one you know you just
prioritize it based on your life plan so
just think that through and then save up
a little bit more that's a great um
great perspective all right we've got a
call from victoria
in decatur texas hey victoria how's it
going
hey i'm good how are you good what's
your question for us
um so i'm just going to give you a
little bit about me and then i'll give
you a question because it makes more
sense
um so i kind of got out of a
relationship where i had
like no freedom so now i have freedom
and i'm basically kind of starting over
and i'm starting over as a single mom a
22 year old
and i have about fifteen thousand
dollars before i said debt
and then nineteen 000 in dental work
that i need done
and the expenses of my daughter so i
guess my question really is just like
where do i start do i go back to school
or do i just keep my job and work on
expenses and work on moving out because
i love
my parents like i'm just curious on
where's a good start for me
to get to where i can fully support
myself and my daughter
alone yeah well first of all you are a
hero
and you are enough for your daughter i
am a daughter of a single mom and
uh she raised me for most of my
childhood as single mom and
and you're a hero let me just say this
and i want anthony jump in here too
before we have to go to break
uh write it down write down everything
you want to do and when you see it on
paper it will take the overwhelm out of
it
when you see it you can do it you just
need to write down what do you want to
do and prioritize
those things those expenses debt
smallest to largest definitely get on
our every dollar budget
but writing it down i think will take so
much of that overwhelm out of it
well this wraps up this hour of the
ramsay show
i want to thank producer james child
associate producer kelly daniel
and my co-host anthony o'neal
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey guys this is kelly associate
producer for the ramsay show
did you know that over 16 million people
listen to the ramsay show every week
and a lot of those people listed on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country
to find a station near you head to
daveramsey.com
show
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsay show where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life
and your money i'm christy wright i'm a
ramsey personality
best-selling author of the book business
boutique and my new devotional living
true
40 days to get back to you and
co-hosting with me today
is anthony o'neil who's also a ramsay
personality and best-selling author of
debt-free degree
we both have shows anthony has his show
on podcast and youtube the table with
anthony o'neill and mine is the christy
wright show we would love
to connect with you there and hear your
stories and get to continue the
conversation we love helping people
in personal development and faith in
money in business
and in life we're taking your calls you
can give us a call at triple eight
eight two five five two two five and
we're going to go ahead and go to the
phones we've got a call from
kurt in albany new york hey kurt how's
it going
good how you guys doing good what's your
question for us
yeah i'm 30 years old i have around 30
000
saved i put 10 000 of that aside as an
emergency fund and i think i'm on baby
step four or going between four and five
i want to get a call for myself that
might be an investment for 15 000
i want to get information about if that
you think it's a good investment or i
should invest in that some other way
i've got a question about your emergency
fund i think anthony's probably going to
ask that too you're 30 years old in your
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses is ten
is ten thousand dollars is that enough
yes yes
i think it should be yeah what well you
live in new york
yeah albany you live it you must you
must live with your parents
not pay rent oh you pay rent do you have
roommates
no i'm i live alone or you live alone
okay how much is your rent
my rent i used to pay 1500 now i pay
900. oh
okay all right so three months single
person i can see that 10k is good
all right all right yeah um uh so that
means
it'll leave you over twenty thousand
dollars right uh to spend towards a car
it means and you said you could find a
car for about 15 grand
yeah i found one that i want which is
actually the 15 is good because usually
i go for 20 000 so i thought maybe it
would be a good investment something i
can enjoy
because i like you know going to the
track and racing and doing that stuff
and
the car isn't going to lose much more
value because it's already a used car
do you already have a vehicle yes okay
so are you trading this vehicle in are
you keeping it
i'm gonna keep it that's a i have like a
beater car i just get around it
nah yeah so at your age you don't need
two cars
no no yeah yeah i would definitely if
you want to get the car
okay um i would trade in this car get
5k for the car you're only spending 10k
cash
um uh so that's what i recommend i mean
i'm 36 years old man i just bought a new
car
and i had another one i was thinking
just like you i'm gonna i'm gonna keep
this car
drive this every day as my beater might
get go to work hard and drive my fun car
on the weekend so i'm like man that's
just unwise just sell the car
um get some money for it have it go
towards the new car that you want
and so that way you can you know you
don't need two insurance policies you
don't need two gas bills
you don't need two maintenance things so
at your age man you have an option you
can keep the beta car
and stack up some more money and go buy
you something a little bit nicer down
the road and until this one uh
well whenever this one dies off or since
you already got a position
you're out of debt you got your three
months set aside for emergencies you got
an extra 20k
if you want to go ahead and upgrade your
vehicle now go ahead and do it bro
how much money do you make kurt i make
uh
before taxes i make about fifty thousand
a year okay
yeah and the other the other thing to
remember and i think this is good for
different people listening right now at
different baby steps or financial
situations
also look at your percentage of income
you don't need two cars
with that type of income that's a fine
income you can continue to increase it
you know in in the future
but you know if someone was calling in
and they're a millionaire and they want
to buy another car yeah okay buy another
car yeah
it's a small percentage of the overall
picture so we just don't want you to be
strained financially where a large
percentage
of your income is going to something
that's unnecessary like
two vehicles you don't need two vehicles
you can have the new car like anthony
said but just sell the other one
and that percentage christy is 50 you
don't want your
cars to be worth more than 50 percent of
your take-home pay
bottom line okay and so i will go ahead
and trade that car in man
and then just boom um drive nicer i mean
just go ahead and trade in and just
drive nicer man but you you've done
great kurt yeah
um i'm proud of you bro uh i just don't
don't don't pay for two car insurance
not right now you don't need that
expense over your head
awesome all right we've got a call from
tim in
appleton wisconsin hey tim how's it
going
good afternoon i'm doing well how are
you good what's your question for us
my question is my wife and i are
currently in baby step four five and six
we have two children 10 and six and the
question specifically is about
baby step five with my younger son
he has i'd say moderate special needs
he's moderately autistic and right now
we see kind of
two paths for him one where he could
he may not where
an education uh beyond high school is
not in his future or where it could be
and i guess the question is how do
parents and other circumstances what
should we think of to try to plan for
that
i'll jump in from the parenting
perspective of what i would do
for my kids and then i'll have ao jump
in from the financial savings
perspective i would say
tim what i'm always going to want as a
parent
or anybody who should want that i mean i
think anybody wants this i just want
options
yeah and so i would i would not make a
decision about your child's future
as young as he is that he will not want
college i would say let's save up for
college in an option that is accessible
to use for something else in case he
doesn't go to college
but gosh you want to have the option
because if he gets there
and then how proud would you be how
excited will you be you want to have the
money to pay for it if that's what he
wants to do and if he doesn't then you
can redirect that money to something
else he wants to do
but i just wouldn't write off that
option this early in life i just i
always like lots of options and money
gives you options i don't know you jump
in there you wrote the book debt-free
degree you know about this
college i'm excited and i love your
heart tim i mean i love how you're
saying hey i want the best for my son
i'm
hoping for the best for my son but i
also want to be wise
uh with the resources that we have right
now for your two older children
are you um already investing into a 529
already for them
yes sir with my oldest uh we have two
children the oldest
uh child we do have a 529 and we
actually have 529 for both
of the older and younger child okay cool
so here's the thing
i wouldn't open up a 529 for your
younger one because here's why you
already have two
open and your 529s can be passed down to
all of your kids
so once you um invest let's say that
your second
to oldest one goes off to college and
you don't use all those funds let's say
they get a scholarship or you have
too much in there you can transfer that
down to your son
if your son goes to college if not then
you can still use it
to fund your your kids college so um you
have options like christy said which i
love that she said that so i will just
go ahead and just max out
the two uh put as much as you can in the
two five 29's you have right now
and then just continue your options you
can also
open up a maybe a mutual fund uh for uh
your your thought your third child so
that way if he does go off a different
route you can still sew
into your your son's future but i
wouldn't open up a 529 though
yeah it's a great question tim and i
think if you if you have this savings
you will just feel the peace of mind of
knowing that whatever you want to do
when that time comes you can do it yeah
and that's what money gives you it gives
you options
and options give you power absolutely
this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
cliff and i joined christian healthcare
ministries because we really like the
concept of
christians sharing each other's burdens
and we really experienced that firsthand
when cliff
was diagnosed with heart disease it was
just such
a relief to know that financial burden
was going to be taken care of
chm is the original and longest serving
health cost
sharing ministry get started today and
check us out
at chministries.org backslash
[Music]
budget
[Music]
i'm christy wright sitting in with me is
anthony o'neil and we're taking your
calls about life
money and business here today and this
has been fun we've had a good
variety of calls we're going to go out
to mesa
arizona with chad hey chad how's it
going
hi doing well how are you guys good how
can anthony and i help
yeah real quick thank you so much for
taking the call my question
is whether i should continue to rent a
home for my family
or with the environment today try to
purchase a home
uh the reason this is a concern is i'm
married to my wife who is currently
changing our status so she's not working
and we just welcomed our son
he's about a month old now and i also
take care of my mother who has dementia
and my niece who we have custody of
prices on houses are going up and really
for
the size of house we're looking for it's
kind of difficult to afford yeah
um i have no debt whatsoever and aside
from a fully funded emergency fund i
have about 75 000 in cash and savings
accounts
okay okay what's the rest man let me
answer that question
i'm sorry what was the question what's
the rush are you just fearful that
you know you may not be able to get into
a home well you have a lot of people
that you're taking care of what's your
home situation
right now as well okay so um
our household income is about 85 000 a
year
um the rush it's really
to give you context we had already had a
contract on a home but
it was a new build that wasn't able to
be finished due to
not being in compliance with
arizona environmental quality so
essentially the contract of the house is
going to be canceled because it won't
build the house
my concern is i keep on spending money
on rent each month
and um you know not owning a home which
i feel is the next step
but at the same time home prices are so
expensive
i was kind of thinking either trying to
purchase land and build a home on it or
waiting for the prices to drop on homes
but i just don't know that that's going
to happen
so that's why i'm really just kind of
reaching for uh you know help with this
yeah it's it's interesting i'll jump in
just from
from my vantage point the good thing is
you have options
that can also be an overwhelming thing
because you've got money
you could buy a house right now but to
anthony's point you're not in a hurry
you don't want to overpay and one of the
things that you said that was a little
bit of a red flag to me chad
is you sound like you were in a very
stressful season of life
you just had a baby so you have a
newborn you also have
other family members you're taking care
of so you're pulled in a lot of
different directions
if i'm you i don't want to build a house
right in the middle that
i don't want to be thinking about what
kind of drawer pools i want
in the middle of that now if if a house
came on the market and it was a good
it had the amount of rooms for your what
you won and you could afford it
i don't think you you totally pass on it
you know i don't think you're like no
we're not gonna buy a house now but i
don't think you're in a hurry too it's
almost kind of like a
if the right thing came on the market
you would consider it
but you're not gonna rush and force it
you're not gonna overpay
but you're also not going to look at
renting as oh i'm just throwing money
away because you're buying yourself time
and options in this season of life when
you have
a lot going on right now that's my gut
anthony you you talk about this a lot
from
especially the financial standpoint what
would you say no you hitting good you
you're talking real good right now
chrissy
um chad i'm gonna wait to 2022. here's
why
um you just had a newborn your focus
should be focusing on a newborn
your focus should be helping your wife
get up in the middle of the night and
get this baby taken care of
you all shouldn't be stressing about the
newborn
plus picking out the colors of this and
the carpet for that and wood grain
floors for this no
focus on that now once you all get
new to this new life that you have uh
then you and your wife can proceed
forward
um i i would definitely take this year
to just relax
um i get it you sound young like myself
and like christy
and so when we see like man i'm renting
and i'm wasting money and i don't have a
mortgage
that i was there i can't speak for
christy uh but i was there like man i'm
young i make good money i should go buy
a house
but you you you can buy a house
at the wrong time and it can hurt your
future man moving forward
a lot of people are going out here and
spending twenty thousand thirty thousand
dollars over asking price
uh for a home right now which is unwise
and so for me the housing market will
come down
um it's not going to stay up this high
forever because if so
we all in trouble you know i'm gonna be
real
and and so for what i'm telling you is
sit still continue stacking this money
um enjoy your new life and then
here's what i will add like chrissy said
if
the only way i'm buying a house this
year is if a house comes in a market and
it is a crazy deal
it is exactly what me and my wife want
and there's
no stress it's already built we can uh
put our down
payment on it and get into the house
that's the only way but i'm talking
about it's below asking price is
is great it's a great deal but right now
man enjoy your new family and enjoy
this season that god is out i mean you
have a new boy you know enjoy that
um get some peace get some joy and then
next year
going ahead and build a home for you and
your amazing family
yeah and history shows if you look at
the housing market
over the course of forever it goes up
and it comes down
it goes up and it comes down it will
level out there's a lot of weirdness
right now because of covet and people
moving
states and then you've got uh the way
the housing prices are
are reflective of people moving in that
state for example nashville is one of
the top cities in the country to move to
we have a lot of people moving here
from california which is jacking up the
prices because people in california got
some money to just pay cash on some
houses
and so you there's a lot of variables at
play right now that will not be at play
forever
and so you're in a great position just
like anthony said to just wait for the
right thing
and the right thing for you right now
might just be focusing on that baby
and getting used to this new season of
life and then when you're ready
going ahead and looking at buying a
house all right we've got a question
from gabrielle in fairmont minnesota hey
gabrielle how you doing
hello thank you for having me my
question simply is this
my mother who just left a 30-year
marriage
is now staying with me and i'm taking
care of her
in the process she's had family help her
financially
she just received a seamless chat now
she's
saying i'm going to pay back all my
family members and so forth right now
what i suggested is no mother find ways
to use that stimulus check
and multiply it then pay back your
family if your family is not
putting a burden on you to repay this
then why are you doing it
she's placing the burden on herself when
she doesn't have to
am i correct in giving her this advice
what what do you have in mind for her
when you say multiply it
meaning as a proverbs 31 woman we really
um we take something out of nothing
and making out of something i my mother
has many gifts
such as sewing she has gifts of cooking
i'm saying
let's take that money and multiply it
use
gifts and then see if it can multiply
she however wants to keep her word to
the people but the people that
she wants to pay back they have not
burdened her to pay it back at a certain
time
um anthony all right
i'm going to jump in and say that one of
the things i love about this question
gabrielle
is i love your mother's heart i would be
way more concerned to hear a question
from a mom that's not really interested
in paying back family
that's not really interested in paying
their debts they're perfectly fine with
owing family members so i want
i would encourage you to hear the
goodness in her intention
and in her heart um the other thing i
would remind you of is
she's a separate person and you can't
make her do anything you can give her
advice but she's going to do what she
wants to do
i would say that the the great thing
about this question and situation
are the two options of her taking that
money and in your words
multiplying it maybe she starts a
business or does something with it to
make more money with it
is not bad advice it's also not the only
good advice
for her to pay those families debts is
also a good option so we really have two
good options here that's the way i see
it anthony we have two good options
it's not like a bad one and a good one
um now i love helping women start side
businesses and small businesses
i am with you i love helping people make
money doing what they love
that's what i do through business
boutique through the event and through
my book
i would also say that starting a
business is not for everyone and so
if she wants to put that stimulus money
to family
that's an okay thing it's her money and
she can do what she wants to
answer i'm so glad this segment came to
an end
it's at the end of the day it's her
money and her life and she can do what
she wants but i
you can absolutely give her that advice
if you want to there's nothing wrong
with that at all but i would just
encourage you to see the good
in her intentions it seems like to pay
this family back as well
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm kristy wright co-hosting with
anthony o'neil today
and we're here for a couple more
segments if you have a question
about money business life or just a
decision you are facing we would love to
help give us call triple eight eight two
five
five two two five we have a few more
minutes to answer your calls and we're
going to go out to new orleans
with heather hey heather how's it going
hey
how y'all doing thanks for having me
sure what's your question
okay so just uh in general i'm a mom of
three
a single mom of three and i'm just
i live paycheck to paycheck and
i just got the stimulus of course the 56
hundred dollars and most of that went
to just paying off my credit card
because that's literally after i paid my
bills
that's what i'm using to put food in my
house i don't get food stamps
because i they say you know of course
you make too much for food stamps but
you're still struggling to eat so you
get like you're in this catch
right so i'm just looking like i don't
know if i should do
a career like i don't i only have a ged
i'm a great worker and i make 30 uh
close to 37 000 a year but raising
three girls you know one of them that
just got braces right
and then it's just i'm literally i'm
just
tired of the check to check and i don't
know just looking for some
personal advice yeah i hear you heather
and the fact that you have those three
kids that you're responsible for
i hear that in your voice that
responsibility not just the money just
the responsibility
and being a single mom like i i hear
that in your voice
i've got a few more questions for you
just to get context around your
situation then anthony and i want to
give you some
some some hope because you you need hope
and and there is hope i want you to hear
that when the lord does come through
like i don't want to act like god
because when i tell you
if you see what i make and then when i
put out it's literally like a miracle
all the time yeah but it gets to the
point where it's like god
when am i'm gonna stop you know like i
do get it i do get like he gets the
glory but it's like
you get tired you're tired of struggling
the the check to check you get tired of
and really it's so stressful that i do
block it out and i just do what needs to
be done in the moment
but you know times like this when you do
get a big chunk of money
and it all goes out which i'm thankful i
get to pay off the capital one and the
asi
and the asi loan because i have asi
credit card on the asi loan
so i'm thankful i get to bring that back
down you know to zero
or little but it's what's gonna happen
is
you know next month's gonna come and i
still need to put food in the house and
i still need to buy
clothes and you still have pictures that
come up and you know i'm saying school
pictures and
soccer teams and you know what i'm
saying all that does come with it
yeah right yeah and i
and i hear you um what are the ages of
your kids
so i have a 13 year old a 10 year old
and a three and a half year old
okay all right i'm gonna go ahead go
ahead
i was going to say i just started
getting child care assistance for a road
which is my which is my three and a half
year old so that has been a burden
lifted because i was paying 620 dollars
a month
and i just got child care assistance in
august
so that has been a blessing so it went
from 6
20 to 375 a month right for her
and they actually paid they actually
feed her graphics
and lunch which is huge because i was
having to do breakfast and lunch at her
other daycare
so heather let me heather let me ask you
this let's let's start from the very
let's start from the very beginning um
because i'm with christy i
i hear the passion in your voice i hear
i'm tired i'm i hear
what do i do i hear
um i want to be a great role model for
my kids i hear
i need help i hear i'm grateful for all
the financial opportunities and the
blessings god has given me i hear it in
your voice
and so i i want to say we hear you
now let's step aside and let's talk
about some practical things
that we can do to help you the very
first thing
that i hear you saying that i hear you
not saying that i hear you saying
you see what i'm saying uh i can almost
guarantee you that you do not
budget that you do not spend yeah
so when i do i get stressed out because
it doesn't make sense
heather i i hear you let's walk you
through because we only have about
three to four minutes and i want to make
sure that we give you some practical
stuff because i hear you i already know
what you're thinking
i'm already flowing with you i know how
this i know how this goes down i mean i
have family members just like you
i'm in my family the very first thing is
um
heather is uh you cannot
rack up more debt thinking you're going
to get out of debt you need to stop
swiping your credit cards you need to
stop
taking out loans if you want to change
the situation
you have to stop borrowing more
money that's the very first thing and
the tool
to do that is the budget i want to call
it like right now what i think you
what i heard you say heather is you have
to use the credit card to put food on
the table because you took the money you
had and put it towards the credit card
listen a budget will solve that problem
when you begin to look at how much money
you have
where it's going to go you allocate for
your four walls
and food is one of your four walls
before those credit card payments
right you make sure food is taken care
of then we pay the credit card companies
in order of priority and you make sure
food is taken care of
and you're still working on your debts
and re uh continuing to swipe the card
is not a part of that plan sorry go
ahead yo i want to jump in on how that's
that makes it possible that was good and
then also you got to be you got to be
okay with saying no
and saying no to yourself and saying no
to your kids okay
uh uh pictures huh no
i thought the same thing i mean pictures
sucker
no i got it sorry i gotta jump in on
this one too listen
i i will tell you no no
my mom was a single mom she never told
me no now this is not a secret me
gossiping about her she knows that she
never told me no because there was
something in her
that wanted to compensate for the fact
that she was doing this
by herself during those years of my life
when she was doing it by herself
your kids are not going to make it in
life
despite the struggle because you
insulate them from from any
hard times and you give them everything
they want soccer pick suckers and all
this thing
they're going to make it because of the
struggle when you invite them into the
struggle with you and say hey we as a
team are going to rally
and we're going to make some short-term
sacrifices to get out of survival mode
for long-term reward and you bring them
into this team picture yeah that is
going to shape their character
more than soccer or pictures will so i
just want to say
you're not harming your kids by
withholding some of these
unnecessary things that are making you
sink
hey yo go ahead sorry i just want to
jump in i i i've seen that firsthand
yeah we're talking
dad teaming here this is good i mean
because here's here's the truth heather
and we're about to come up on a break so
we can't we can't spend too much time
here because we i just want to give you
some practical stuff
stop borrowing money number one number
two get on the plane get on a budget for
your money
and the key thing here is when you do
your money your budget
you need to list everything and when you
go back through the budget
i need you to identify where can you cut
certain things out of
now yes thirty seven thousand dollars is
not a lot of money which i'm gonna
number three
you need to connect with our career
coach here our career expert ken
coleman he's going to show you how to
get your
shovel which is your income up okay
he's going to show you how to write the
right resume because just because you
have a ged
doesn't mean you have to stay in the ged
category
i know several people who have geds and
they they've become
very prestigious very high-end earners
individuals so number one get on the
budget
that's number one is stop borrowing
money number two is get on a clear
budget see where you can cut
all right if you got netflix and disney
plus cut out netflix
rock over to disney plus for your kids
all right then number three
monday through friday you need to be
listening to ken coleman on siriusxm or
go to kingcolemanshow.com and you need
to
call into his show maybe on monday he's
out of town this week on vacation with
his family
but on monday ask him hey what can i do
i'm tired of this i need i need a better
job i need some more income
what can you do do that that's the first
step
all right stay stay on the line i'm
gonna have madison give you
a free year to ramsey plus which is our
proven
plan to help you get out of debt and get
your money in order but you gotta do it
okay heather we're gonna give you this
ramsey plus i want you to watch the
video lessons
i want you to use the budget i want you
to really do it when you have a plan and
you put it on paper you can see
what you need to do and i just want you
to hear from us you can do this
you will do this and when you do i want
you to call us back and tell us your
story
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm christy wright joined by anthony
o'neil we're taking your calls about
life
money and business here for just one
more segment all right we've got a call
from kristin
in salt lake city utah hey kristen how's
it going
good how are you guys good what's your
question for us
thank you so much for taking my call i
have a lot of information so i'm just
going to jump right in my husband and i
were in the middle of
baby step two we had about twenty
thousand dollars of debt we're down to
about six thousand
um about six years ago before we knew
about you guys we bought a house of
course that we couldn't afford
that we now found out my husband is
finishing up his bachelor's degree
and then he will be applying for pa
school or physician's assistant
schooling
um we decided to move in with my mom and
we've been renting from her to save
money to be paying off debt we've rented
out our home
and that lease is coming up at the end
of july this year
so we've kind of thought about selling
our home
to be able to cash flow his pa scoring
because pa school we're hoping he gets
here
in state so it's you know cheaper
tuition but it can go anywhere from
eighty thousand dollars to two hundred
thousand dollars
just for pa school plus he's not allowed
to work during that 28 months of the
program they don't allow him to
so we're thinking of selling our home
right now our home uh
we have about 186 thousand dollars left
on it
and low right now that we've talked with
our realtor low what it could go for is
about 340 thousand
high is about 370. so we'd be able to
get a good profit we could be able to
cash flow his schooling and be able to
even have some
monthly you know kind of income coming
in during those two years
to be able to live off of so my
questions are is one
is this a good idea are we heading in
the right direction
um two about property gains tax i don't
think we qualify for that but i just
want to be prepared in case we would all
that
is since that is a large sum of money
we've never
had that much money so where's the best
place to keep that
because we'll also need to be able to
have access to it right when like
tuitions do
you know monthly payments things like
that yeah how long have you been in the
house kristen
uh six years yeah so you don't have any
capital gains tax on it
no they're renting it out they're living
with their parents oh coco yeah
so it would be for example we've had the
house six well we've had it for six
years and we've only rented it out this
last like this july will be a year
so you lived in it for more than two
years then yes
yeah so you won't have capital gains
taxes because you lived in
five yeah for two more than two years um
okay
so you're looking at about 200 some
thousand dollars in equity in your home
um okay cool let's say you cash flow
this experience
what are you what is your income uh what
is your family income now
our family income now um is about
35 000 right now a year three little
kids
yes okay and then my husband won't be
able to go to
like work at all during those two years
okay cool
and then once he has this once he
finished school
what will his income go up to yeah the
average um for starting out pas if we
stay here in utah
is about eight thousand a month eighty
thousand so we're looking at about a
forty five
thousand dollar increase in pay
that can potentially go to about 120 125
once he's
in his sweet spot yeah for about yeah
i i don't i don't have a yes or no
answer for this i think
it depends on what you and your family
want to do the other thing to consider
what i hear in your voice and maybe i'm
maybe i'm misunderstanding this but
one of the things i hear in your voice
kristen is it sounds like we're going to
sell this house and we're going to have
all this money you're not gonna have you
live with your
mom yeah with three kids that
that can't be a long-term plan not for
you not for her not for the kids not for
anybody
and so i just don't want to look at the
sale of this house that we have so much
money what are we gonna do with all this
money because you really don't because
you don't have a place to live right now
so
my a1 priority would be what is your
housing plan if you're going to sell the
how the home that you own
that you're currently renting out what
is your plan
to move out from your mom
yeah our plan for now what we talked
about if he goes and we've
worked out a plan that we would live
with my mom while he finishes school
and um plus it's 28 months
oh that's two and a half years we have
her we have
yeah we have her full basement um
because she lives alone
and you know she's single her health
isn't the greatest so we try to help her
out as well
okay so it kind of works both ways it
helps out and obviously it's not ideal
but like i guess what we just saw with
that as well if we do that if we can get
done with like
school because if not we could have like
a couple like a hundred thousand dollars
or more in debt
and you know what i mean no
so that's why i don't want to do that so
if we sell the house and we do have that
lump sum of money
we can use that to cash flow schooling
we can use it for
um you know like kind of like our
monthly expenses why my husband's not
allowed to work during that time so that
was just kind of our
our idea with that yeah so here here's
the
the the short answer that anthony and i
are helping you with is
it comes down to priorities yeah if your
priority is this school
and as a family you're saying this is
our number one priority we're willing to
sacrifice
living on our own we're willing to
sacrifice the amount of equity we've
built up in this home that we've been in
for six years our own for six years
we're willing to sacrifice all this
because the number one priority for our
family at this stage of life
is pa school then it's your money yeah
you can do what you want to
just know if six months down the road
you're like man this basement's feeling
real small
this is really hard i wish we had our
own place that was a decision you made
to prioritize school over having your
own house or even renting your own place
that's a little bit more expensive for
your family of five so i just
i really want you to think it through
before you do it
it's not you can do it it's your money
that's rough
that's rough two and a half years
basement family of five
that's the only thing that i'm just a
little fearful well and it's it's hard
the thing that i think people need to
keep in mind is we're always gonna have
our
personal values as a filter and for me
and i try to always remind people of
this like well this is my personal
opinion but i
value independence so much that there is
almost
nothing that could get me to go live
with my mom
right because i want my own independence
and so i would i would do school slower
or in a different time frame or figure
out how to save up ahead of time i would
do something else to avoid that if that
was the requirement but but
but everyone's not like that if it's a
great situation and you make a good
point that you're helping her
with her health and that could be a good
fit for you in this season of life if
it's if it's what the family wants to do
then yes you can do it i just really
want you to think through it but it's a
it's a great question i think it's
awesome that you're able to help your
mom
in the process all right let's go to
paul in dayton ohio hey paul how's it
going
hi thank you for taking my call yeah
what's your question a little
little background before my question
real quick i'm 40 years old
uh household income is 50 000 i'm an
electrician by trade
and wanting to start my own business i
was hoping to do that
last year one of the things that i need
to do is obtain a
state license to
i love my job but one of the things
we've got going on this year is we've
got a new baby coming we've got a
two-year-old already
and i cannot keep up the full-time job
my day job uh do side work which i'm
pretty busy in
study for a five hour exam and have
responsibilities of a new baby
it's too much too much going on so one
thing i thought about is
when the baby comes quitting my
full-time job
and doing side work um
and preparing and also study for that
test
yeah what do you think about that or
should i just tough it out and take
longer
studying for the test take the test and
then quit the day job
yeah it's a uh it comes down to what we
were just saying you just got to
prioritize
you've got to put an order of what you
want to do i know that it's a lot but i
will tell you
when you're starting when you're
starting a side business on the side it
feels like a lot it feels like you're
working two full-time jobs now if this
isn't the right season to do that
because you've got a new baby then that
is totally fine you adjust to being a
new dad that's so exciting
and then say okay in three six months
and the baby's sleeping a little bit
more i'm a little more arrested i can
think and steady
then you're willing to take on that
workload
great question i want to give you guys
the scripture of the day
galatians 6 9 let us not be weary and
doing good for at the proper time will
reap a harvest
if we do not give up and then i think
that the good and the great
are only separated by the willingness to
sacrifice
kareem abdul-jabbar that's a theme for
today the willingness to sacrifice in
the short term
for long-term gain this has been fun
anthony
thanks for hosting with me this is a
good day christy you you killed it man
this is awesome
i want to thank our producer james
childs associate producer kelly daniel
and you america for hanging out with me
and anthony
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
you